[Music]
yeah
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
them so so let me get this straight
you want to own the
libs with open
borders oh I'm I'm going to tell you
something right now dark Brandon is the
most brilliant the most evil genius in
politics ever in the history of ever
think about
this dark Brandon
has
has has put the Republic Republicans in
a position where they have to own the
libs by keeping the borders
[Laughter]
open and the best part is they're
fighting they are fighting over a bill
that is
conservatives wet dream for the last
three decades this bill is absolute [__]
I know that people keep saying oh and
the media are like this is the greatest
bill it's bipartisan listen folks this
bill is the wet dream that Republicans
have wanted for migration in this
country for decades it is one of the
most limiting bills of migration that
we've ever seen even at the Republican
conference this bill is absolute [__]
[__] it's garbage and the Democrats know
that they never ever ever have to vote
on it they don't have to vote on it they
don't have to vote on it not in the
house they'll never have to vote on it
in the house and Joe Biden from now
until the election can tout that he
backed the most conservative immigration
Bill and Democrats get to stand back and
pretend that yeah great he wasn't gonna
[__] sign that
thing oh dark Brandon is the most Evil
Genius the best Evil Genius of all time
all time in
politics we should recognize that here
I I don't normally toot Biden's horn by
any means on this show but this is one
of the best political jiujitsu moves
that has ever been
pulled this is fantastic they went from
it's all the democrat's fault that brown
people are in this country and then like
hell no we're going to own the lives by
Lon brown people in this country it's
really weird we're not really sure why
but that's what we're gonna do
as if Democrats care if we have migrants
coming in this country to assimilate be
part of the American Experience the
American dream the American way th we
want diversity we want Equity we want
inclusion we want Liberty for all people
in this country and all people who want
to come here that's what we want that's
what liberals well the new brand of
liberal I do have to say that it's the
new brand of a liberal that wants that
liberals out there are starting to
understand what Liberty actually is and
how it works in our government and how
that we must activate and engage in our
democracy to get Liberty to work for all
of
us but it's [__]
great it's [__]
great that they're gonna own the
libs by having open borders honestly ly
I think Greg Abbott by tomorrow will be
taking down the razor wire opening up
the gates come on in come on in we're
gonna own the
libs so now Donald Trump and the house
Freedom
caucus are the party of open
borders and Joe Biden and the Democrats
are the part party of border security
and that is what you must pretend I know
there's going to be a lot of things that
you're going to pretend to like in the
next six eight months that is going to
seem very weird and very backwards it's
okay it's all right we will we'll make
it work I promise you that oh [__]
maggots pretend all the time
conservatives have always pretended
Republicans have always pretended I mean
Jesus Christ they're pretending that the
border is the is the most existential
crisis it's going to destroy our country
for people come here and want to
work for people to bring their children
here and want to be part of the American
Experience that's going to destroy our
what the [__] how don't you know history
at all the [__] out of here with this
nonsense that people coming to our
country is a bad thing that's a good
thing that's a good thing that's not a
problem it's ridiculous to say that
that's a problem what we do when they
get here that's the problems that we we
have we have those problems and I've
seen a lot of this bitching and
conservatives on Twitter they're like oh
let me tell you something let me tell
you something Suburban moms are going to
be really mad when they find out they're
giving thousand gift cards to migrants
coming to this country why do you think
that is
bonehead it's probably because they were
getting a child tax credit in their bank
account under Joe Biden and the
Republicans blocked it from happening
again why do you think they're going to
be mad they're not mad because the
migrant's getting it they're mad because
they're not getting their child tax
credit they're not getting their child
tax credit because
Republicans it's always the fault of the
party of
no they're truly the party of no no
don't give me what I want Joe Brandon
may be able to take credit
good [__] them [__] them [__] them [__]
them we must band together in this
effort even if it takes again a little
bit of pretending that we have cognitive
dissidence I know you're like God do we
want to be like them well do you want to
win do you w to win big because if you
want to win and you w to win big get
with it get with the program here ah
people pretend all the time like this
immunity thing this morning you've seen
this that of course oh man who could
have predicted that the that the appeals
court the appell court was going to
Strack down that Trump has full immunity
because he was President of the United
States that's the dumbest [__] I've ever
heard of in my life that that decision
was going to be anything but a three
decision one of them being a [__]
Republican
but I flipped it over to the MSNBC to
see what dumb [__] Inc was saying holy
[__] [__] Neil Cel and I know people
don't like when I attack liberal
attorneys but I don't give a [__] I
attacked Glenn yesterday I'll tack Neil
today it's the dumbest stupid [__] ever
giving telling people lies he's lying on
air on MSNBC as an
expert that yes the Supreme Court
totally could take this up and a week or
two they're not going to they're not
going to fast walk this immunity thing
and the reason why is because it's
pretty [__] simple he doesn't have it
you [__] Dum Dums and there's no
reason to [__] rush to a trial there
listen to me listen to me there is no
actual reason to rush to a
trial the courts there's no [__]
deadline there's he's already charged by
a grand jury
the statute of limitations aren't going
to run out or
anything
judge
J the judge is g to be there the courts
will be there Trump is going to be there
hopefully he doesn't die before he's
criminally in in a criminal
trial or maybe I don't know whatever you
want but there are no reasons to rush
and the I mean I know you feel like
you're like yeah but Tony the election
and oh my God he's gonna
and that's not a legal reason that's not
a legal
reason that's not a reason that the
court is going to take in consideration
because it's not part of what they do
it's
not judge chuin said in the very
beginning in the very beginning she said
I'm going to treat this guy just like
I'm going to treat Mr citizen Trump just
like any other
citizen any other citizen that's how I'm
going to treat
him and that's how she's going to do it
she's not going to do it any other way
and if you go look at Chin's history
there's nothing nothing in Chin's
history and I'm actually happy about
this there's nothing in chk's history
that suggests that she will go outside
the bounds of what is
normal I'm happy about that I'm happy
that chuin is actually the judge in that
case we need
someone who would heere to normaly to
any decisions that's made in courtrooms
won't be able to be overturned in an
appeals court that's [__] important
to me it should be important to you you
shouldn't be listening to Neil Cel give
you a bunch of [__] load of [__]
to make you feel good and have hope that
in two weeks you'll be disappointed
again what sort of [__] is that and
why are we still acting like these
people are [__]
experts it's the dumbest [__] I ever
seen and I know I know people yesterday
are mad that I that I'm knocking on
Glenn I'll knock on Neil today because
it's
nonsense it's nonsense and it hurts the
pro-democracy movement if you want to
know the qu the honest truth and the
reason why is because it gets people out
there saying [__] that just ain't true
they start spreading misinformation
the court is not going to rush to this
immunity decision they're not there is
no reason
to there's no reason to and yes they are
going to take this up the suggestion
that they won't they won't take it up
and it'll get kicked back to chuin
automatically with tomorrow is dumb as
[__] it's dumb it's dumb stop stop
wanting things that aren't going to
happen stop telling people [__] that
ain't real stop saying the fck stop
concentrating on the [__] criminal
trials anyways just mock him with them
just mock him stop worrying about them
just use them as
mockery that's it and one of the
best one of the best pieces of mockery
right now other than the dude thinks
Supply chains you know a chain has links
in it you know and when you have a
supply of a product or a service there's
you know links in the chain
it's a chain not a
change not a change but he thinks it's a
supply change and he's never heard of a
supply change and the reason why is
because Supply
changes aren't a thing they're not it's
not a it's not a phrase anyone's heard
because it's not a phrase the phrase is
supply
chain yeah we're definitely going to
mock that today but in the documents
case with judge Canon apparently Donald
Trump and I'm just people are saying
this people are saying that Donald Trump
hired an attorney who doesn't have a
computer on purpose there I said it now
people are saying
it I believe that Donald Trump did you
hear this so apparently in the documents
case Donald Trump's attorney's like oh
man I can't look at this discovery
there's no way for me to do my job
because I can't see it I'm having
technical
difficulties so the FBI and the special
council's like okay we'll help you we'll
help you with your technical
difficulties that way you can see the
discovery so you can defend Donald Trump
so we don't have to delay this
anymore the attorney's like I don't have
a computer liter
Donald I love it I love
it Donald Trump hired an
attorney who doesn't have a computer
this is real that he did not own or have
access to a laptop or desktop computer
he he does have a tablet okay I don't
know if it's like a like one of them
Amazon Kindles or something um but he
has he has a tablet apparently
um yes people are saying it's the my dog
the dog ate my computer
excuse when I heard that that's what I
thought of I was like the dog ate my
computer I don't know what to tell you I
don't know can't look at the discovery
H like literally literally Donald Trump
think about this as a strategy right you
think that this is out of the realm of
possibility no it's not it's not this is
so dumb that this actually sounds like
the plan that Trump and his and his
attorneys made is they're like look what
is the best possible to delay with this
discovery what if we found an attorney
who wasn't able to look at the discovery
well what do you mean by that
sir well what I mean is what if we hired
an attorney who didn't own a computer
like is there a thing as a as an
attorney who doesn't own a computer so
then imagine this they go to Craigslist
we're looking to hire an attorney
without a computer we definitely don't
want them to have any conspir skills
whatsoever it would be nice if they
didn't even actually own a computer
[Laughter]
he hired a [__] attorney that doesn't
own a goddamn computer now I mean a lot
of people don't own computers nowadays
because with smartphones and tablets
yeah you can
do most [__] knew most [__] with a
tablet or a phone these days that you
couldn't do you know four or five years
ago but here's the thing here's the
thing an attorney someone who's in
business I I if they if you believe that
they don't own a laptop or a
desktop
baby
baby Jesus like Windows 95 up in this
[__] typewriter only oh man it's
hilarious it's hilarious and then I'm
gonna show you um again I'm gonna show
you video today of Donald Trump
confusing a supply
chain with Supply change change I don't
know this like change in your pocket I
know if this is like hope and change uh
like Obama oh I just got an idea all you
creative people out there listen up get
your ears ready I just had an idea Tony
Michaels just had an idea live on air
and we're gonna get creative together
open up your ears what if someone you
remember the um the Obama poster hope
and then change remember those hope
change what if you had
a what if you have a fentanyl furer
poster like that with him like right and
then underneath it says Supply and
change I'm just saying I'm just trying
to create man I'm just giving you these
great ideas and putting them out into
the world so that the world can [__]
them back out at me that's all I want
that's all I want
oh yeah people have been taking um the
meme Workshop that we did the other day
seriously a lot of people are are now
meme makers they're meme makers here at
the [__] fam um I'm telling you we're
gonna actively engage in this election
and um you know come hell or high water
we're gonna obviously we're going to win
this right but we want we want to pile
up as many votes as we possibly can uh
and and engage people to go to the
ballot as much as we possibly can I want
lines around the [__] blocks that's
the videos I want to show you on
Election Day there [__] people
waiting in line for hours not because
not because there's not in a polling
station because there's so many [__]
people voting and I want to pile that
stupid son of a [__] and all the manga
allies underneath just mountains and
mountains of mailing ballots too that's
right we're going to these mailin
ballots Republicans you [__] maggots
you Cheeto humping [__] nuggets just to
piss you off just to piss you off really
honestly if if your state allows a
mailin ballot right if your state allows
a mailing ballot do it that way yeah
[__] them I mean yeah do you want to go
to the poll sometimes and mark down and
it feels like you actually voted
sure I get it but [__] let's have some
fun with it if we're going to do it
let's have some [__] fun with it
let's let's pile them underneath as many
[__] mailin ballots as we possibly
can get them you know what I mean oh
[__] that'll piss them off goddamn
[__] [__] you [__] with
your mailing
ballots get it
going find out how to vote by
mail
piss them off I mean Jesus they're
trying to again the narrative should be
right now right now the narrative should
be that Republicans are owning the libs
with open borders think about that
that's literally what they're doing they
are owning the libs so that Joe Biden
doesn't get a
win they're owning the libs with open
borders so they're the party of open
borders now
they're all but saying it too I mean
they
are what do you
want what do you
want it's what they want they want to
own the libs with open borders say it
type it out go make go make [__]
memes go watch the meme workshop on
YouTube go make [__] memes and pile
those things on social media speaking of
piling things on social media you really
should go join the
Discord because they're going to be
they're going to be sharing all those
memes that they're making here let me
show you how to get there you just go to
Theon michaels.com you pan on down to
membership and join the Discord server
right here it's
free it's the home of [__] is what it
is the absolute home of
[__] by God that's what we should be
doing every single second of the day
that we
[Laughter]
can oh boy I've already
here we go here we go I've already got
one oh
boy I got one I got a a supply change
maybe if I can make it work here where'd
it
go where'd it go put that back in there
damn
it send it over to me but you guys
should go join the Discord server and
the reason why you should uh join the
Discord server is so that you uh can
participate in the
[__] what do I mean by that you can
go you can make your own memes right and
then you can share it you can share the
meme you can share the meme if you
want this is all things that you can you
can do to help um Save the
Planet here's the uh here's the one we
have now I'm sure this one will end up
in the U in the Discord before you know
it here it is Supply
change oh is this the change you were
looking for sir is this the change
um and it's called over on
Discord it's called the meme Legion
that's where you're GNA want to go if
you go to the Discord server you're
going to want to go to the meme Legion
we have skip over there the uh the clip
master and we've got Derek as the meme
General um so they're making Clips all
the time they're finding Clips they're
posting
things we have shubao over there as the
lieutenant writer um you see some of
these AI things that happen and we've
got a lot of stuff coming we got a lot
of ideas and really honestly if we all
got together and put those ideas
together can you imagine the clitmas
well I mean he might be that too but
clip Jesus Christ you people I talk
about a neck Gino one day one day I
bring up
Trump's neck vagge and you guys can't
stop Supply change at the ports of
Entry oh my
god oh this is the proper mockery that
I'm talking about and let me tell tell
you something if you're if you want to
mock Trump and you like to mock Trump
and that's that's your goal in life
which it should be your entire goal
should be to mock Trump and MAA because
[__] kind of rolls downhill right [__]
rolls downhill and I know it feels like
oh but if we just mock him then we might
not win these other races no no no no no
no no no no we will 100% win these
Races by mocking him and mocking Maga
that's the entire point like I said
they're going to own the libs with open
borders all right what what oh you got
me got me oh man oh boy that got
me that really really got
me with the supply and the
change to own the
libs for open borders at the porch of
entry on the borders of Terror
ISM these are all things they've said by
the way they're all things they've said
not me not me I'm just pointing it
out sping and pointing out what what
other stories do we got there's so much
good stuff going on in the world today
in the world today there's so much stuff
going on in the world today there's the
immunity case h again there's the
there's the owning owning the
libs by having open borders um Tucker
Carlson went to Russia to interview
Putin I'm guessing he went to you know
give information I just wonder if maybe
um Tucker Carlson was carrying a flash
drive I don't know I mean isn't aren't
these questions we should ask was Tucker
Carlson carrying a hard drive of
documents that possibly a fentanyl fiend
had given him to give to Putin could
this be possible I'm sure that it's
possible that Tucker Carlson had a would
we be ridiculous to believe that Tucker
Carlson would pass a hard drive to
Vladimir Putin with classified
documentation from the United States of
America that was stolen by a fentol
fiend of course it's possible anything's
possible I'm just asking
questions I'm just asking questions
Tucker [__] [__] Tucker Tucker
sucks George Carlin said that by the way
ah George Carlin such a man before his
time you know what I mean even even
before he knew Tucker Carlson even
existed he knew that Tucker Carlson
suck what do you want from me I'm
feeling good today you should be feeling
good today today is a good day in our
democracy it truly is it truly is a good
day in our democracy don't listen to all
the naysayers don't listen to all the D
[__] definitely don't turn on the TV
and watch Fox News o Newsmax MSNBC or
CNN it's complete [__] and if you open
up the tubes of you beware what you
watch over here too Jesus [__] Christ
you talk about a bunch of [__]
liberals spreading around a bunch of
misinformation that could hurt our
chances to pile these fascist scum
underneath mountains of
votes beware out there and don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza magic eat pepperoni hugs spot
Pizza your tummy say thank you your
mouth say m pepperoni hug spot it's like
family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thony Michels we're back to
the king of Brilliance this is the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast well I haven't said Taylor
Swift's name yet in this broadcast so I
might as
well we got to bring up Taylor Swift
it's the week of the Super Bowl what do
you want me to do it's our main scop
it's the main focus on the liberal
agendas to have Taylor Swift win the
Super Bowl she scored a touchdown at the
Grammys so you can't stop talking about
Taylor no one can stop talking about
Taylor cuz we invented Taylor Taylor
isn't actually real she just um she's a
hologram believe it or not it is a she's
a hologram that the Liberals come up
with and the Deep State come up with
years ago it really didn't it's and
she's not even real like um it looks
real it's it's like the best AI we've
ever come up with that's why we piled up
so much shitty AI you know what I mean
like the pizza Commercial you just seen
because we want to confuse people you
know what I mean we want to confuse them
by thinking well AI isn't that great
really but it's been great for years
that's all Taylor Swift is she's not
real are you serious come on man she's
not real she's been AI the whole time
the whole idea was a scop we made her
famous the AI Taylor we made her
famous we uh we put her out there we
gave her hit records oh my God that was
that was brutal to try to get so many
hit records we made her International
Superstar and then we convinced Travis
gelyy to fake that he was having a
relationship with his a i that's what we
do here at the antifa corporate
headquarters in Kami Falls Missouri
where I broadcast live every single
weekday it's we come up with these scops
we come up with these ideas and that's
how it
works
man what do you want from me these
[__] people believe anything you tell
them oh no well I mean they still think
JFK Jr Michael Jackson's
alive what do you want for they think
JFK Jr is going toak with Trump this
time or some dumb [__] you think it's
not out of the realm a possibility that
they'll think that Taylor Swift has
never actually been real of course it is
of course it's not out of the real
possib oh maybe it is maybe it isn't but
I will tell you I will tell you one
thing what we need to get going is an
idea we had
yesterday um and the idea we had
yesterday is that we should
convince we should convince dark Tony
Amy Says dark Tony hang on I'll get back
to this dark t i I am 100% AI I've been
AI the whole time I'm not actually a
real person it's all made up it's all
made up I'm not real it's the machine
you're just seeing some sort of AI thing
I mean you know we had to make the AI
look beautiful and attractive of course
I mean why else would you you know the
same reason why we came up with the
Taylor Swift
AI come on
man anywh who the idea that we had
yesterday uh we need to think about this
idea and we really need to deploy this
idea right and I need your help to
deploy this idea I want to trick okay
and not really trick them into it I mean
kind of like we tricked him into being
for open borders okay it wasn't hard to
trick them into it they're like yeah
Brandon's wait Brandon's gonna get a win
people are gonna say that Brandon
secured the Border no we don't want
border security open the borders open
them up pull up the Bob wire pull up the
razor wire get the buoys out of the
water God damn it we want to open the
borders so Brandon loses I don't know
this is
weird so what I want to do here's what I
want to do okay because I think we can
actually convince these [__]
boneheads of this [__] all right bear
with me bear with
me I
want to get a rumor started that
liberals and swifties want to change the
name of the camp Kanas City Chiefs to
the Kansas City
swifties okay think about the commentary
that I could play on this show that we
trick Charlie Kirk or Ben Shapiro into
by convincing them that liberals want to
change the name of the Kansas City
Chiefs to the Kansas City swifties now
I'm all for [__] and I really don't
even care how we make this [__]
possible I don't give a [__] I don't
care how we make this possible alls I
want is is a plenty of clips of of
Charlie Kirk Ben Shapiro and these other
right-wing morons saying that liberals
want to change the name of the Kansas
City
Chiefs to the Kansas City
swifties I totally want to [__] with
them okay I don't even care if I get
credit you get credit I don't give a
[__] it doesn't matter at this point who
cares I just want clips of them saying
this [__] that's all I want and honestly
I really think we can Farm content from
from the right you know what I mean so
like if we want to play a right-wing
clip of Charlie Kirk or some of these
dumb [__] saying some stupid
[__] on here right we totally can bait
them into saying that so it creates a
clip and then it ends up on the show so
like we're
like we're creating their content
being to put on our show
right I think this is a great idea now I
need your help and we need some help
planning this and that's why I tell you
all the time that you should go visit
the Discord page um again go to dton
michaels.com hit subscribe at the top
don't forget to subscribe I'll email you
every once in a while like it's very
rare that I'll email you it's got to be
something big and important and then you
pan on down to memberships and you join
the Discord server we actually had the
book club and Rachel Dr Rachel boff's
book is out and she's on book tour and
I'm sure as soon as she's done with that
we'll be able to get her in the book
club and do a book club of her book hit
them where it hurts um I'm supposed to
get my Advanced copy it might be in my
PO Box I got to go check that so it
might be there I got to go check that um
but join the Discord server and we'll
try to make a plan here we'll try to
make a plan here let me put the oh oh
the moderators had the let me put the
link uh to the Discord server in the
chat here while we're talking here um
but I'm serious I think I think we can
trick them into
believing don't you guys think we could
trick them into this I think we can
totally trick them into this and the
believing that yeah yeah that the left
wants to change the name from the Kansas
City Chiefs because we can be like oh
the Chiefs that name is offensive you
know what I mean like we can take that
route like whatever you want to do if
you want to be like oh that name's
offensive it's talking about Native
Americans in a derogatory way which I
don't think it really is I don't think
the the Chiefs that name because the
Chiefs are like they're the leaders of
the tribes right so I don't think that's
offensive maybe some people do I don't
think it's offensive I don't think it is
when when like the the the Indians the
Redskins that you know that suppor line
offensive you know some people are going
to be offended by that I'm not cuz I'm
not a Native American so I wouldn't be
offended so but Native Americans may be
offended the point is this it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what matters is is we're trying
to farm content to these right- Wingers
so even if we got to get some
journalists or some websites out there
to publish articles where they're like
heyy people are getting offended by the
name Kansas City Chiefs they want to
change it to the Kansas City swifties
I'm okay with that I'm all right with
it I'm 100% okay with it let's get it
going that's all I'm saying how we can
get it going is everyone join up in the
Discord server and start throwing out
your ideas that's the nice part about
Discord too is that it's kind of like
our own private little social media
community so they can't [__] with us you
know what I mean if we get some maggots
or some spies or some [__] in our
Discord server we can choose to leave
them there you know because that's
proper [__] too I'm not going to lie
when you get maggots in the Discord
server sometimes that's proper [__]
they usually leave pretty
close right they usually leave without
much hassle well I mean you know they
say something stupid and the server
piles on top of
[Laughter]
them Cynthia is Right Discord is where
it's at like this is where we can
organize this stuff that's why that's
why I I realized the Discord server was
such a good opportunity for the [__]
them fam and and really the pro
democracy Coalition anyways and really
the reason why my Discord server and our
Discord server and the [__] them fans
Discord server is so good is because I
truly don't give a [__] right I don't
give a [__] I don't I don't care um it
says Discord page blank Tony what does
that mean does that mean that the
[__] thing ain't
working no it's working you just got to
continue to
Discord and you may what you may have to
do is verify okay so when you go when
you go to Discord you got to go to the
Welcome Center or the actually hashtag
get verified and you're gonna get
verified you just click the little green
check mark is all you do that's all you
do and there's instructions in there on
how to on how to verify there's
instructions on how to verify just get
verified and it's not that difficult get
yourself verified just go to get
verified and click the green check mark
just click the green check mark under
get verified at the at the Discord
server and I know you're like ah I don't
want to F [__] I don't wanna I don't
want to learn another thing this may be
the only one that you need to
know and your favorite social media
platform here's why possibly right so if
we create group [__] inside the
Discord server it might be the let's say
it's a great meme that someone created
maybe you created a meme and you posted
it in Discord in the meme Legend right
and everyone's like that [__] meme is
banging so everyone goes and grabs that
Meme they download the meme to their
phone or to their computer computer
which apparently Trump's lawyers do not
own computers but if you own a computer
you can download it to that computer and
then what you can do is go out to your
favorite social media
websites
wwww do
facebook.com I feel like I'm explaining
how to use a computer to Trump's lawyers
now too do you think
that can you
imag can you imagine the FBI and the doj
they have
to go to some guy's [__] office he's
like 90 years old or some [__] and he's
like this is Trump's lawyer the guys are
like uh we're here to we're here to meet
EOB Crane attorney at law for Donald
Trump we're gonna teach him how to use a
computer they're like What's the what's
the last piece of techn techology that
you Ed Mr cran well uh well it was so
long ago but uh I used to use a an a
slide ruler to to calculate
calculations I I only have a typewriter
that's the um that's the greatest piece
of technology uh since the printing
press was the typewriter and I use the
typewriter what the [__] are you serious
yep yeah is going to teach him is going
to teach him how to [__] how to
[__] use a
computer okay let's get back to the
[__] let's get back to the subject at
hand [__] here
organized organized PR
democracy
[__] so go to the Discord server go
down to memberships Tony Michael podcast
join the Discord server get verified
over there just go to the get verified
part when you see it you'll see it on
the left and it says hash get verified
click on that pan on down there's a
green check mark box that you want to
click it you want to click it okay this
ain't a typewriter it's goddamn cell
phone or computer gotta use your
computer you got your computer there huh
you got your
computer oh my God but that's that's the
best that's the best way that that we
can organize our [__] is get in there
in the Discord server start talking to
each other I mean the best part is is
like you find some some [__]
right-winger to [__] with right maybe
maybe there's like a YouTube or a rumble
broadcast of one of these [__] shut
ass [__] right maybe there is maybe
there's some kind of broadcast that
everyone can go I don't know just say
all kinds of crazy [__] in their comment
section like sh in the Shar Army does
I'm beginning to think I was having um a
conversation with the laboratory we were
trying to figure out if shz is a robot
or if shz is in a foreign
country that's what we're trying to
figure out trying to figure this
out but maybe maybe just maybe the
right-wing by deploying deploying Shar
Army lieutenants like Shaz maybe they
don't have a maybe they're not having
bad ideas here maybe these aren't bad
ideas maybe these are good ideas that we
could use to [__] with
them [__] with him every day of the
[__]
week all the time everywhere [__] with
them because folks this [__] is so easy
their hero Tucker Carlson went to suck
suck off Vladimir
Putin
okay
fullon Putin's
puppets Donald Trump is asking for
presidential immunity but he says he's
innocent this [__] doesn't make sense
what do you need immunity for if you're
[__] innocent huh what do you need a
pardon for Matt gats Scott Perry
margerie Taylor green what do you need a
pardon for if you're [__] innocent
huh these things are so easy you're
going to own the L Libs you're going to
own the libs by keeping the Border open
so now the Republicans are the party of
the open borders folks this [__] is so
[__]
easy they're not even throwing out rakes
anymore they have the most
technologically advanced bear traps
these bear traps even have more
computers than Trump's
attorneys okay and these are the best
Bear Tracks ever bear traps ever and
their throwing them out and they're
jumping in the bear
traps I'm telling you we have an
opportunity here in this election not
only to win the presidency of the United
States that one's gonna be [__]
easy it's gonna be [__] easy so
[__]
easy I've been telling you this for a
long time that we should not we should
not worry about Joe
Biden we should not worry about what Joe
Biden's doing how the election's going
for him are black people going to vote
for him are Muslims gonna vote for him
are young people gonna shut the [__] up
stop worrying about that
[__] Joe Biden is doing just fine he's
getting up in the morning and he's doing
his [__] job what we need to do is
our [__] job what our job is is to
point out to the rest of the country
that doesn't know it
yet that the maglites the Trump humping
idiots the Cheeto humping [__] nuggets
in this country Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets have lost their goddamn
minds and it is definitely something
that you want to vote against not only
do they want to take away women's rights
to Health Care they want to criminalize
pregnancies they want to ban they want
to ban privacy in doctor's offices they
want to take away your parental consent
by writing bills in states that would
allow faculty and administration
to legally molest children because they
want to go to the bathroom with genital
checks it's a thing they want to do away
with public education okay they want to
do away with it they want to they want
to make sure they want to make sure that
12 13 and 14 year olds not only can
marry adult men but they can get jobs
too they're lifting labor
laws for
children they sent a convoy
of pedophiles to a children's camp in
Texas to defend the Border but they
stole food from the children and the
orphans
okay there is plenty of narratives out
there that you should force the media to
be talking
about because in all reality the worst
threat that we have to our country is
white Christian
nationalism and our best way to defend
it and to get the entire country to look
at it and say look look look at these
crazy [__] look what they want to do is
a little bit of [__] and a hell of a
lot of
mockery so let's get with the [__]
and let's make the mockery on
point and so loud that they can't
[__] ignore
it it's what the right does so well it's
what they've always done so well and I'm
I'm tell telling you we're going to have
the blueprint with Dr Rachel boff's
book hit them where it
hurts so you've got the option you've
got the option here you can say can we
treat this like normal times and let's
just you know start talking about court
motions and get hopeful that let's hope
that Donald Trump is going to go to
criminal trial before before the
election
and let's hope that America pays
attention to a criminal trial that won't
have cameras so there's nothing to pay
attention to or or you gonna make the
choice to make sure they [__] hear
you no matter
what be damn the criminal trials be damn
how much money they they [__] put on
him to have to pay egene Carol to the
state of New York be
damned it's time to get
real
it's time to get
raw and it's time to hit him where it
hurts just the title of Dr Rachel
bofer
book [__] them [__] them [__] them and
by God if we gotta start a goddamn rumor
that liberals in this libtards in this
country did you breaking news did you
hear what the libtards want to do they
want to change the name from Kansas City
Chiefs to the Kansas City
swifties and I want you to be part of it
because here's what's going to happen
all right are you following me this is
how the news Cycle Works let me tell you
how it works if we create this this
rumor that the right- Wingers cannot
ignore they won't because listen to me
listen to me when I tell you this
because what they're trying to sell to
their bunch of [__] white fragile man
male incels is a is a bunch of [__]
incel crack right oh my God woke wokeism
woke this woke at and wokeism and wokers
you mother wokers they love that [__]
man oh my God they [__] love that
[__] they love the wokeism crack don't
they a they [__] love it they love it
more than they love chocolate cake and
trust me these [__] listening
to Charlie Kirk and Ben Shapiro and all
these [__] chuds definitely
definitely 100% love them some chocolate
[__]
cake no
question
but they won't be able to resist the
Kansas City Swifty story they won't
resist and here's what'll happen they'll
start talking about it right and then
[__] on Twitter be be be do we
do be clipping Charlie Kirk says that
the Liberals want to change the name
from the Kansas City Chiefs to Kanas
City swifties they'll be writing that
and putting clips of Charlie Kirk and
then we'll put it on our and then like a
week later the mainstream media will be
like did you know that a bunch of
liberals want to change the name from
Kansas City Chiefs to Kansas City
swifties and we all we only got a few
days to do this it's [__] Tuesday
folks it's Tuesday we got to make this a
goddamn Story by the time the Super Bowl
happens so we got to get in this Discord
server and we got to come up with ideas
no matter what no idea is a bad
idea trust me in this this effort no
idea is bad idea and the best part about
it is when when this comes up on MSNBC
or you see this in your Twitter feed
you're gonna be like oh my God oh my God
if these people only knew if these
people only knew that this dumb [__] was
created in a Discord server where some
[__] rodeo clown has a goddamn TV
show that people calling the rustling
ball the
left it was us it was us that did it it
was us that did it I think we can do it
I think we can do it I think we can get
people to participate in this [__] I
really do um so go go to the Tony
michaels.com get in the Discord server I
know this sounds like a weird Mission
but trust me this is a mission worth
having oh [__] yeah and the reason why
it's a mission worth having is because
this son of a [__] will have traction
for weeks past the Super Bowl weeks past
the Super Bowl these [__] idiots will
continue to talk about [__] Taylor
Swift
Swift continue to talk about Taylor
Swift and be completely completely
[__] oblivious to the fact that they
just they just stopped the most [__]
conservative immigration bill ever in
the history of our country they stopped
it because to own the libs because they
don't want Joe Brandon to get a [__]
win it's that um someone says here r C
LC if you Google smell this the the
first result is Tony Michaels are you
serious ah we're doing this hang on
don't go anywhere smell this let's see
smell
this I don't know smell this there's a
smell this
records I don't know how true this is
let let's see here here I'm going to go
to this tab here I'll show you this here
is it the images that you're talking
about it might be the images so here's
the thing there's actually a smell
this oh my God there's a smell this
records baby if you go down you can buy
you can buy smell this and
bulk oh [__] me what the [__] all right
let's see let's see let's let's click on
images maybe it's images that you're
talking about images smell
uh no I don't I don't see me anywhere it
must just be your your Google
machine uh videos maybe smell this
records smell this records
presents smous records is a thing
apparently I don't see where I'm number
one it must just it must be your Google
machine um thanks thanks that let's see
if um RCC can clear this up
yeah
images could be well I'm not I'm not the
top one um where is this Melvis image
here there's that one there's that
one none those are my images though I
mean I stole them see that's the best
part about [__] in the internet is we
can steal stuff we don't have to um we
don't have to apologize for it either
they'll thank us later don't worry like
when you steal an ai ai image like this
this one right here and you put your own
words on it like in the meme maker that
we
um that we showed the other day um
that's proper [__] it's internet
[__] I don't see anything on here
must just be your your Google machine
loves me that's what it is your Google
machine loves
me I think that's what it is rclc thanks
for pointing that out though thanks for
pointing that out right
all right
let's let's um let's let's take a quick
break when we come back we'll we'll
continue some more [__] don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul goar and thanks to my new product
pardon blanket I've got you covered
paron blanket specifically Works to make
you feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup
Hardon blanket will protect you too
Hardon blanket is made of a sort of soft
fleece and a layer of sheep's wool and
they're 100% made in the USA don't delay
and get your pardon blanket today for
just
$99.99 actual pardon's not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the
show hello hello hello how are
[Music]
you
fastic that's how you
[Music]
are
fantastic uh let me show you um some
[__] here the
um so
um yelis shitler yelis instead of smis
um this is this is smell's half brother
okay this is smell's half brother this
is yelis shitler um not to be confused
by smis shitler this is yelis they look
kind of the same it's
[Laughter]
um oh go spread that one
around I don't you know it's listen this
is a um oh here's his here's his brother
performing as well here's here's yell
the shitler here here he is look at the
[__] yesterday I I did a I did a
front butt front butt segment I was
talking about the the uh smell this's
FAA
um um if you don't know what a FAA is go
look it up uh but you don't need to know
this is a FAA but yesterday I was
talking about um smell's front butt you
remember the front butt segment yeah I
did a front butt segment yesterday star
staral asking front butt segment yeah
hell yeah we did a front butt segment
don't you remember we're talking about
his front butt here his his FAA as it
were but it was smous not yelis yelis
shitler is his brother he's got a FAA
he's got a front butt but it might be a
full diaper too this is possible for
people out there who've had children
before with diapers when they [__] them
and it's an explosive type of
bomb that drops in their diaper
sometimes it like moves up to the front
and it's like godamn you filled the
entire [__] diaper full of [__] I
imagine that's how Trump is what do you
think it's like when Walt NADA has to
change one of those has to change a
diaper like this huh what do you think
you think Walt regrets his decisions in
life um when he has to change a diaper
like this Jesus [__]
Christ prop ER
[__] oh boy so we really do need to
get this idea going though speaking of
[__] proper [__] we really you
need to get this idea going so get to
the Discord server make sure to get
verified click the disc go to dton
michaels.com click the Discord server
button here we are I I don't know
exactly how we're going to do it if you
got ideas right now in the chat you can
I don't know you can post them right now
if you want I'm going to post the um the
Discord server link right now I'm just
poting in the chat here so if you want
to join Discord click that link there
make sure you get verified go to Hash
ver get verified and click the green
check mark in that thread you just click
the green check mark and that'll get you
verified so you can see everything it's
not that Discord server actually is in
blank you got to verify to get in so go
ahead and
verify um but we're we're going to try
to convince the rightwing that there's a
liberal
movement there's there's a libtard
movement
of how about those Kansas City
swifties that we want to get the Kansas
City Chief's name
changed to the Kansas City swifties
maybe we could use that sound right
there how about those Kansas City
swifties huh how about those Kansas City
swifties I don't know any ideas that you
got really honestly um what you should
be doing too is reaching out to
journalist and saying hey have you heard
this idea people are people are saying
people are saying that this that
there're Swifty because I'm I'm an
honorary Swifty now I think we can say
that right are you an honorary Swifty is
there like a like a because I know with
antifa like here at the corporate
headquarters of antifa where we
broadcast from every single weekday
Monday through Friday in commi Falls
Missouri every single weekday we
broadcast here to get your antifa
membership card you kind of gotta verify
you know what I mean a little bit and
then there's gold memberships there's
bronze
memberships there's all kinds of
different levels of memberships at
antifa because it's an organized Club
you know what I mean we have bake sales
we have meetings all kinds of good stuff
we have seances too for all those people
out there that want to get on the in on
the blood sucking cabal part of antifa
we got seanes too I don't know if the
seanes and blood sucking if that go
coordinates with like um the way it
happens but I don't care I don't give a
[__] we do it all here at the antifa
corporate headquarters in Kami Falls
Missouri we do it right here um where
was I going with this oh yes oh yes oh
yes go make sure to email all the
journalists saying that people are
saying swifties are saying in fact
swifties are saying in fact that they
want to change the name from the Kansas
City Chiefs to the Kansas City
swifties that's what we want to do we
want to get this name change to the
Kansas City swifties now again if they
ever find out that this is me this is
heresy in Missouri like me speaking
against Trump is one thing but me
getting a rumor spreaded that the Kansas
City Chiefs want the name Chang to the
Kansas City swifties whoo baby I bet I
bet if we do this good enough
we could even get a shout out on the
[__] Super Bowl football game that's
right they can even say hey have you
heard about this story where they want
to change the Kansas City Chief's names
to the Kansas City
swifties and then they panned to Taylor
[Laughter]
Swift I'm telling you we can do it we
can do it it ain't that hard we just
need everyone working in concert here um
and it'll [__] with the right wiers
it'll [__] with everyone in this country
everyone will pay attention it'll get
people to have a discussion about
politics and make decisions because
that's what we need everyone to do right
what we need to do is get everyone to
make a decision we need to get them to
make a decision as soon as possible um
start an online petition Z kr999 get in
the Discord and drop that idea get in
the Discord and drop that idea it's fine
by me whatever we got to do
hell we'll start a hundred online
petitions I don't give a good
godamn I don't care even if we have to
pretend to be offended by the names
Chiefs I'm okay with it and you may be
offended by the names
Chiefs and that's how we wna that's one
of the angles to get the name changed
fine whatever let's do it I don't want
to commit
[__] some people are going to be like
Tony you're breaking the law they're
going to say that they said I was
breaking the law with AI when I posted
Taylor Swift endorsing dark Brandon they
said I'm breaking the law and I'll
probably go to jail there's a few people
that send that
comment people are wild you you people
have been listening to Glenn kersner way
too much whoosh you [__] lefties out
there that watch these [__] legal
analysis all the time
you're you ever watch some of these
legal analysis you would have thought
that Trump went to prison 14 times
already oh man this is the big one this
is the big motion this is the motion
that's going to motion motion the ocean
at all Trump's going to prison for sure
on this one
100% oh man no way no way is this not
GNA [__] bury Trump and beneath the
prison sail this motion right here so
stupid
so stupid it's dumb it's like this
morning about this immunity thing did
you hear three to zero they ruled that
presidents don't have immunity from
anything and everything who could have
guessed that was gonna
happen I mean listen the [__]
arguments that Trump's attorneys are
making are really shitty in the first
place and honestly it hurts his chances
in trial because they're going to be
able to use these Court decisions and
their arguments in these [__] in
these [__] appeals and [__] of
immunity against them against him
they're going to be able to use it and
it's going to be
fantastic so why do you want it to hurry
to trial when we could just wait and
just have more of it to [__] pile on
top of this dumb
[__] but Neil Cel I'm telling you I
heard the immunity news this morning so
I switched it over to MSNBC to see what
their dumb asses were saying and they
did not disappoint
holy [__] they did not disappoint Neil
Cel on MSNBC is saying stupid [__] that
ain't gonna
happen stupid [__] that ain't gonna
happen he's like yeah so if this this
this and this and this and this happens
then we'll go to criminal trial
tomorrow the [__] out of here man what
are you talking about man listen let me
tell you the God's honest truth about
federal court listen open your ears turn
this on make sure you remember this
about any kind of legal analysis you
hear from here on out in federal court
they are not in a [__] hurry okay
understand this in federal court they
are not in a [__]
hurry just operate under that simple
fact okay just that one little
nugget that's all you got to do man
that's all you got to to do that's it
that's all you got to do is know that
federal courts don't give a [__] about
time they don't care they're not in a
hurry they have huge schedules they
don't give a [__]
okay the federal government has has a
lot of power they have a lot of money
they got a lot of time even if a
prosecutor leaves even if a judge leaves
they don't care they'll put another utor
another judge in place and the the
[__] time schedule will just
continue it's not complicated to
understand that measure of the truth
it's not and when Neil Cel or Glenn or
anyone I don't care if it's legal AF or
Midas Touch or Ben melis I don't care if
it's Harry Litman which Harry Litman is
very measured because Harry Litman keeps
that in mind if you listen to Harry
Litman he keeps that in mind talking
feds listen if you if you're saying com
commentary without that simple
Foundation of truth that the federal
courts do not get in a hurry you are
[__] lying to people either that or
you're misinforming them one or the
other and if you're if you're
misinforming them meaning that it could
be true and you may believe it but it
doesn't make it true it's just
misinformation it's not it could be the
truth but it's not the truth so it's
misinformation but if you know these
things and you're you're intentionally
telling people these things like Neil
Cel was saying [__] on MSNBC Neil Kel is
not an
idiot Neil Cel is not an idiot uh RC LC
says Litman lman is the opposite of
Glenn number two I don't know if he's
the opposite but he definitely is much
more measured about I don't know reality
than Glenn Glenn's selling hope to
people who want to buy hope he's not
he's and he's doing it with
misinformation or lies however you want
to look at it however you want to look
at it and people get mad when I say that
[__] but hey man you get mad at me all
you want but you're ma you're mad at me
you're mad at me because I'm pointing
out that someone's doing something so
you're mad at me oh okay all right that
makes
sense I pointed out that Glenn misled
people and you're mad at me
so you're not mad at him for misleading
people you're mad at me for pointing it
out that's really [__] stupid too
that's really [__] dumb too it's dumb
dumb as
[__] listen we got a lot of [__] we
got a we got a huge huge
huge um someone just
said did Tony just diss mind his touch H
listen if they do [__] that I don't like
and they do [__] like that I'll point it
out yeah I'm going to point it out
that's why I'm independent that's why I
don't affiliate with any Group is
because someone has to be able to point
this [__] out damn the torpedoes Full
Speed
Ahead you have to win you got to win and
we need groups like mindus stutch we
need Glenn in the fight with us not
[__] creating alternative narratives
in right-wing media that works against
us they never the left never [__]
thinks about this [__] the media doesn't
think about this [__] because they think
they're smarter like the left thinks
they're smarter the media thinks they're
[__] smarter than all of us and
they're not they're not smarter than us
okay they're just
not and they believe that they get to
control the narrative they get to
control what people think I actually
believe the
opposite I believe in Liberty I believe
in independent thought I believe that we
don't have to agree on everything to get
along I actually believe that you could
disagree with almost every [__] thing
I say and you could still come watch
this show and enjoy the two
hours we welcome descent here on the
show if you haven't noticed that then
you haven't been paying attention I'm
okay with people telling me I'm [__]
wrong I'm okay with people telling me
that I ain't right I'm okay with people
telling me I'll go to jail because I'm
putting up Taylor Swift AI if that's the
dumb [__] you want to believe and that's
the [__] you want to type in on your
Twitter fine whatever I don't give a
[__] I mean I'm not going to stop what
I'm doing you shouldn't stop what you're
doing but that's the whole idea right
that's the whole idea is we got to get
to a foundation of Truth and stay there
and stay there and then weaponize
mockery and [__] against the right to
get the rest of the country that's not
paying attention because most of the
country is not paying attention and one
of the reasons why is because the news
wants to talk about every [__] Court
motion every [__] oh look Donald Trump's
in a plane going to a
courtroom who gives a [__] no one cares
about that [__] no one cares that Donald
Trump is in a [__] in a God damn
Convoy a a pedophile Convoy by the way
when Donald Trump's in the Convoy it's a
sexual assault or pedophile Convoy by
the way just is by nature they're
sending a Cony Convoy to a room
somewhere right and that's somehow
[__] news No One Believes that [__]
in this country no one wants to [__]
watch MSNBC follow Donald Trump around
with a camera in a courtroom where he
says the same stupid [__] every day
listen Mar logo is worth a billion and a
half dollars it's where I'm telling you
oh look you just need one clip and him
saying it and then he says it over and
over and over again then you can just
mock him properly use [__] and
mockery to tell the country this guy's a
goddamn chucklehead appearing in a
courtroom but no they normalize
him they normalize
him and to pay attention and act like
the these these court cases are going to
save us is really
stupid it's not mocking him will I
[__] it's so easy it's so easy look
at this [__] here let me show you a clip
from yesterday let me show you a clip
from yesterday and the rightwing is
buying this [__] hookline Sinker because
he said it oh look look our orange
musolini Jesus said it so now it's true
let's listen to him well maybe it's hard
to believe because I think it probably
would mean the end of their career this
is a a Democrat trap it's a trap for
Republicans
that it's a Democrat trap no dude I mean
yeah it is a Democrat trap like it's
literally a Democrat trap here
and Joe Brandon is the most diabolical
Genius of all time like he has he has
pulled the best political scop on Trump
ever in the history of
ever because Trump believes that he
needs the border the border the border
to be at a crisis which it's not at a
crisis they made that [__] up and they
made it up way too early can you imagine
this was like
October right let's say this was October
right now and the [__] and the
Republicans went down to the border for
their photo op they're like we need to
close the border we even though there's
no one coming across today you remember
that when they all went down to the
border to stop all the brown people from
coming in and no one was crossing that
day they're like well we're not really
sure where all the brown people at they
were supposed to be here
today we show up we invade the border
and The Invasion is only us
H you know what we'll do here a couple
months from now we'll have a clan boy
we'll get a bunch of pedophiles to go to
a children's camp and steal orphans food
that'll work that'll get the attention
that there's an invasion of maglites at
the border the only invasion is a bunch
of [__] racist rednecks at the border
that's
it the clan boy is The Invasion that was
it and the Republican conference was the
invasion too they invaded the Border but
imagine if it was October right that we
wouldn't have time for this fod back and
forth but Joe Brandon Joe Brandon is a
[__] genius not only does Joe Brandon
probably have a huge [__] I'm just
saying listen Joe Brandon has a way
bigger dick than this guy we have
confirmation from Stormy Daniels that
he's an itty bitty mushroom he's an ity
bitty mushroom but we have confirmation
from margorie Taylor green that Hunter
Biden's [__] is huge like she is has
presented the size of Hunter Biden's
[__] in a goddamn Congressional hearing
this is Congressional evidence now about
how big hunter Biden's dick is right
it's huge it's [__] massive did you
see the black bar that they had to use
on the porn I mean Marjorie Taylor green
doesn't have it the black bar on it you
know she's always probably jerking off
to Hunter Biden's wean all the time all
the time I'm sure of it but she showed
it with the big blar and it's got a big
it's huge his his dick is big it's a
huge hog okay I'm just trying to make
the
point but a lot of times a lot of times
the size of your
package is inherited and we know we know
that Don Junior's Edy Bey weenie
probably came from his ity Bey daddy oh
you got such a cute little wiener it's
so
cute so I'm sure d Junior's got a small
dick is what I'm saying which by that
measure if we're using if we're using if
we're
using you know reason here it would be
reasonable to believe that the genetics
of penises if Hunter Biden's dick is
huge and it's possible his dad's got a
huge dick too I'm just saying I'm just
saying I don't even know where I was
going with the dick talk I just like to
say that Joe Brandon has a bigger dick
than this guy 100% my president's got a
bigger dick than your president 100% we
can say that that's like that's probably
um as close to fact as you can get I
mean I'm just piling up the fact Kansas
City safties what the
hell that's right how about them Kansas
City
swifties that's probably what I was
talking about it's probably where I was
going with this oh Tony got today Tony
Michaels is talking about Hunter Biden's
dick Joe Biden's dick Don Jr's dick and
the fit and all F's dick and he got off
track he doesn't even know where he's at
anymore I don't know oh yeah the border
the Border we were talking about the
border and how they're going to own the
libs by having open
borders and that that right there is the
thing that we can use now again for this
[__] to work we're going to have to
pretend a bit okay we're going to have
to pretend but when you think about it
there's not much pretending involved
when they're they're going to own the
libs by opening the borders now this is
the thing this bill that he's talking
about here where it's a Democrat trap
right let me play it again it would mean
the end of their career this is a a
Democrat trap it's a trap for
Republicans that it's a trap for
republicans
listen this bill was written by Lankford
Senator Lankford from
Oklahoma uh Cynthia says you're obsessed
with dicks today I might be I've got
dick on the brain apparently I don't
know it happens sometimes you know you
get a dick in your mind you can't get
it's like kind of like a [__] catchy
song you know what I mean it's it's like
a catchy song get a dick in your head
you can't get it out that's the problem
that margorie Taylor green has she keeps
whacking off to [__] Hunter Biden's
[__] she can't get it out of her
head it's like a really really catchy
song It's a trap it's a trap it's a trap
please um the clip
Department it's a
trap okay so this is a trap right let's
get back to the bill Senator Lankford of
Oklahoma who Trump endorsed by the way
who Trump endorsed Trump endorsed
Senator lford and in his
endorsement one of the reasons why
Donald Trump the fentol furer
endorsed senator lenford of Oklahoma by
the way Senator lford is a white
Christian nationalist he's a [__]
racist he's a piece of [__] trash
okay never forget that Senator L every
the media has been acting like Senator
lenford is some kind of reasonable
Senator he's
not he is not he's a white Christian
nationalist scumbag he's a [__]
fascist he's a goddamn America First
Nazi is what lenford
is and really honestly other than Rick
Scott Lankford is the one that qualifies
to look like one of the aliens and Men
In
Black what you want from me I'm just
[__] stating the truth I mean there's
Rick Scott who's definitely a [__] an
alien suit from Men In Black Lankford is
questionable it is
questionable and he's a racist white
Christian nationalist scumbag he's a
Nazi and he's the one that wrote this
bill after Donald Trump [__] endorsed
him because he's tough on the border
literally Donald Trump endorsed
Lanford because he's tough on the border
go look that [__] up if you need to I
don't need to show you go look it up
yeah you just [__] believe me one or
the other I don't care even if it's a
lie believe it
pretend it's not a lie it's real he
literally endorsed him because he's
tough on the border and what he means is
he's racist and he hates Mexicans and I
like that so vote for Lankford that's
literally what
Grandpa Grandpa shitler said in his
endorsement
so Senator Lankford is the author of
this bill and Senator lenford because
Joe Biden's like you goddamn right I'll
sign
wink because Joe Brandon knows Joe
Brandon knows that there's no way that
micro Johnson that racist in the house
not to be confused with lenford but
Micro Johnson the wiener of the house
100% is not going to be able to bring
this bill to the floor and the reason
why is because the Republican party has
a king the Republican party is a cult
and they have a cult leader and they
have to do whatever the cult leader and
the King
says they can't do anything without the
cult Leader's permission they can't do
anything without the king granting them
the amission the the permission to do
these things and there's no way the king
who wants to run on an open border wants
to close the
border no way no how that is not going
to be a thing and Joe B Joe Brandon
knows
it oh man unusual I just got an alert um
from the Discord oh you guys are [__]
awesome you guys are [__] awesome
hang on to this [__] narrative just
for a second I gotta I gotta point out
unusual join activity detected in the
Tony Michaels podcast Discord server
that is [__]
awesome this is what I'm talking about
folks this is how we create a movement
that no one can [__] ignore
and I know it's like Tony we just went
and joined the Discord server yes but
I'm telling you if we band together if
we do these things
together if we do these things together
we will not be [__] ignored
anymore they can't ignore us the
establishment can't ignore us the
Republicans can't ignore us the [__]
Nazis can't ignore
us it's so important and
you give me such [__]
energy such [__] energy from the
[__] fam when you guys do stuff like
that where the Discord saying hey man
you might want to check this out good
God too many people are joining son of a
[__] there's a ton of people joining
your Discord server that means you're
down with the
[__] you're down with it there's so
many people joining the Discord server
right now that Discord is like whoa whoa
whoa where did all these [__] people
come from and they're wanting us to
review it Katherine Reynolds says what
is happening what's happening is is
everyone's going and joining the Discord
server that's what's happening and let
me put that link in the um in the chat
box again so anyone who isn't part of it
you're going to want to go join it now
if you haven't already make sure you get
verified when you go in there make sure
you get verified the link is in the chat
box right now you can go to the Tony
michaels.com too you can go to the Tony
michs
you pan on down to memberships and the
Discord servers right here it's free it
doesn't cost a single [__] thing to
join the Discord server and it's going
to be free [__] in there what I mean
by that is we're gonna have memes and
videos for you to share we're gonna have
news articles all kinds of [__] all
kinds we're gonna teach you how to
[__] commit proper [__] all over
the internet on your favorite platform
if you like Facebook the best boom we'll
teach you how to do [__] there oh you
like YouTube Boom we'll teach you how to
commit [__] there you like Twitter
godamn can we teach you some Twitter
[__] to [__] with these
people [__] with these Nazis get inside
their [__] little tiny skulls make
them Ed the couple brain cells they got
to rub
together to try to create thoughts and
arguments against us
good it's what we need in this
country so Senator l lford let me get
back to let me get back to this Senator
Lanford is behind the Democrat trap here
okay and it actually is a trap it really
is a trap it's a trap that Republicans
set themselves okay I don't know why
they're doing this I don't know why they
went because we had we had we were
opening up rake factories I don't know
if you know that um if the laboratory
can pull up those rake factory images
that we have we were opening up I'm
serious we were opening up rate
fact and shovel factories in this
country just so we could keep up with
the supply
change of rakes it's a supply change
right Supply change of rakes what it is
um my God he actually said that Supply
change I'm going to show you the video I
promise I'll get to it I know we got
like 30 minutes left it's going by fast
today we'll get to it we'll get to it
hang hang hang on hang on don't go
anywhere um but we were we were opening
up rake factories in this country now
now the Republicans are like H we don't
want rakes no no no no no more rakes we
want to step in Bear traps okay the
rakes just aren't harsh enough on us we
want to set bear traps for ourselves and
really this is the dumbest stupid thing
that Grandpa shitler could ever say is
that it's a Democrat trap listen listen
again career this is a a Democrat trap
it's a trap for Republicans that it's a
trap it's a trap it's a trap how is it a
trap how is it a [__]
trap oh that's right because Joe Brandon
made you walk into it Joe Brandon's like
yeah I'll sign any bill that they pass
for border of security
wink win and Democrats are like like
we'll follow Joe Brandon's lead and yeah
we'll vote for B border Security Bureau
yeah sure thing we'll do that go ahead
Senator Senator racist from
Oklahoma go ahead go ahead Senator Nazi
from Oklahoma go ahead and write you an
immigration Bill that'll be great get
Mitch McConnell involved in it that'll
be even better when that shits the
bed this is a Republican bill it is
Republicans wet dreams that they've
wanted for decades listen listen two
months ago three four months ago this
bill wouldn't even be considered but now
it is because of this dumb
[__] and the only reason why it's being
considered because yeah it is a trap it
is a trap we're making you keep the
borders open to own the
libs think about it we're in a situation
right now where Joe Brandon and the
Democrats and the pro-democracy
Coalition has
tricked Senator Nazi Senator Adolf Nazi
from Oklahoma into writing a [__]
border bill that won't go anywhere as a
matter of fact all the other Nazis in
the country going yeah that's some Nazi
[__] but the fentol furer said we can't
support it because he needs to run on
something he needs to run on open
borders so wait wait wait does that mean
we're going to be open borders now yeah
we're going to be the open border party
now so now they're the open border party
they're the open border
party they're the open border
party zkr 99 points out points something
out it's 40 chest or is or is Donald
Trump would say it's listen listen
listen to It's not chest it's chest it's
chest I got 40 chest it's a
chest listen the supply chain of 40
chest is everywhere not chest it's not
chest it's chest chest cuz I got titties
oh boy do I got the best I want to be a
dick taster and I got titties these
titties are gonna be the best dick
taster I don't know I would imagine he's
got a set of
mobs wouldn't you if he's got that FAA
that he's got I showed you the FAA
yesterday this guy's got a huge foa he's
gotta have [__] mobs you know what
moobs are they're man boobs right man
boobs moobs mobs he's got mobies this
guy's definitely wears a bro not a brawl
a bro I know he wears a girdle but you
know this guy's got huge
tits I mean he's got a neck
veg finger in his neck veg and he's got
he's got
mobs movies movies movies are man
boobies and so they AR man tits he's got
he's got a nice rack
probably um so it says manzer n it's the
bro but yeah you could call it a man's
ear as
well Keith says Trump has a [__] neck
he does have a neck [__] he does it's
[__] weird I'm not gonna lie you can
see it from right here you can see the
meat curtains uh hanging from
his his dick taster here you see that
there's his dick taster and here's the
curtains Linda's totally gonna post this
now yesterday I was talking about front
butt and his his man or his neck Gina
and uh Linda totally cut the thing and
put it on Twitter which H made my
[__] day I'm not gonna lie it made my
[__] day if you guys want to clip
this show live and then go put it on
Twitter and just tag me [__] I'll tweet
that [__] I said it I'll tweet it it's
fantastic it it warns my heart and Keith
is right he does have a neck
[__] and he does not know what a supply
chain is I'm not kidding you he does not
know what a supply chain is now let me
see if I can find the clip here um
there's a couple of clips that I want he
calls the
he he called America pathetic too he
doesn't he hates America Trump hates
America he hates where's this [__]
Supply Chain video did I not retweet
this thing I thought I retweeted this
thing maybe this is it maybe this is it
is this it is this the supply chain one
yeah this is it here it is I did retweet
it here is the supply supply chain
change listen we got Supply change in
this country you got Supply Chain
man yeah he needs he needs a man look at
these boobs look at the boobs on this
guy he needs a man's ear he needs a bro
the country's finished I in what regard
uh I think it's not going to be able to
function I think it's look at even
things like Supply change things listen
look look listen listen there's climate
change there's climate change but
there's oh there's something much worse
much worse than climate change it's a
change that's much worse it's Supply
change okay Supply change is a much
worse change
than the climate the climate change it
might be something some people are
saying but other people most people are
saying that the supply change is
actually much worse change much worse
change than the climate changing okay
okay excuse me excuse me we never even
heard about you never heard that term
the country you never heard that term
you've never heard that term Supply
change yeah because that's not a thing
that's that's not a thing that's not
it's Supply
chain chain and usually I don't [__]
with people saying [__] wrong because I
say [__] wrong all all the time I mean
Gabe Sanchez make fun of me how I say
salza salza salza right
salza but this guy really does believe
it's Supply
change wait maybe this is him speaking
qanon you know I'm always talking about
that maybe we're maybe we're off the
Mark here I don't know I I might have
some evidence for you wait wait just
hang on I might have some evidence that
this could be qinon talk he could be
speaking Qing on here uh let's not get
too far ahead of ourselves because I
just I played a video yesterday and it
just it kind of brings in my memory here
of the the emails from God lady you know
this lady that [__] crazy
cook she wants change right and God's
going to change this thing he's going to
supply the change and change the supply
let's listen change is coming in your
news media change is coming in your
governments change is coming in your
just Justice says cour justice says oh
great change what about the supply
change is coming in every part of your
governments what about the changes
coming in laws changes coming in the
streets changes coming in the
church in your atmospher changes coming
in the climate CH coming in your
soil in your water change is coming in
your food
Supply change who's coming in my what
they're coming in my what why are they
coming in my in my water why are they
why why is change coming in my water
that's
weird it's coming in my water okay okay
all right maybe she'll get to the supply
change part get ready for the greatest
change though mankind has ever here it
is here it is Supply change come on
because a great great CL cleansing who
that I am doing doing I am moving and
manifesting myself and I God's
manifesting for the supply change I am
cleansing out your governments I am
cleansing out what they have done to
tarnish the church they have done to
tarnish my name well they have done
against you in shame yeah they brought
the shame on my people what about the
supply did they bring the supply did
they bring the supply slavery and
torment and cap captivity to my
people but change is
coming Supply change is coming it's
coming in your water by the way it's
coming in your
water oh these [__]
people it's so easy it's so [__]
easy we should not be standing around
going how how are they winning already
how are they [__] winning when they
when they steep in when they're opening
up
bare rake factories we're open up rake
factories for them to step on and now
they're open up oh [__] hang on damn
it it's all skipping around on me here
boom there we go they're opening up bear
trap
factories here's the here's the bear
trap Factory we got a um this is an
image breaking news um the supply change
of bear traps is good and we have a huge
supply change of bear traps for the
Republicans to step in one of them being
that they're gonna own the libs by
having open borders okay step in that
bear trap there friend do
it so the supply change of of bear
traps he said that I don't he said it he
said it not me I didn't [__] say it I
didn't say Supply
change I and then he's like doubling
down on he's like no one's ever heard of
Supply change no one's ever heard of
that oh
[__] what else did he say what else did
he say last night in this interview oh
yes oh yes he called America pathetic
that's right he [__] hates America
he's always hated [__] America this
guy's never loved America he's never
been a [__] Patriot he's always hated
this country and the reason why he hates
this country is this country has always
[__] hated him it's always hated him
because he's a [__] loser well let's
hear how pathetic he is ask you the
country is just it's so pathetic and you
know other countries are watching this
it's so
pathetic you don't love it leave it
[__] that's all I gotta say if you
don't love it leave it you piece of [__]
maybe maybe maybe the the supply of
pathet athetic is heavy on you you
[__] [__] ask you the country is
just it's so pathetic it's so pathetic
because I'm a victim boo [__]
who get over it you you [__] saggy
tit [__] go get your man's ear and do
something with the [__] neck [__]
okay listen he could have gender
confirming surgery on his neck that's
what he needs to do he needs to go have
[__] gender confirming surgery on his
neck maybe they can put a bigger dong up
here than he's got down there I don't
know they probably can these days
[__] [__] what a piece of trash
this country is pathetic yeah [__]
you [__]
you piece of human [__] he is he's human
garbage garbage he's human garbage is
what he is 100% human [__] garbage
and he doesn't even know what a supply
chain is the country is finished I in
what regard uh I think it's not going to
be able to function I think it's look at
even things like supply chain things we
never even heard about look at look at
that look at that [__] thing what the
[__] is that thing what the [__] is
this all right not only do we need to
start a
petition to get the Kansas City Chief's
name to the Kansas City swifties we also
need to start a GoFundMe gives and go to
get him Recon gender reconfirming
surgery on his goddamn neck this is I
mean by Republican party standards by
Ronda santis and the [__] book nais
this has to be qualified as porn right
this has to we need a supply change on
this guy's neck [__] look at this thing
this is [__] porn how am I even
allowed to [__] show this on
YouTube I mean literally YouTube's
probably their little you know they got
like a little thing that looks to see if
there's nudity okay they got like an AI
machine that looks for nudity on YouTube
so like if you go post a video and it's
got It's got you know nipples in it or
genitalia in it they might flag it right
now now dead head
dead heads the guy who decapitated his
dad the Trump supporter that decapitated
his
dad because he's a Biden supporter well
he's not a Biden supporter he just
worked for the federal government so
he's part of the deep State he beheaded
he he he cut his dad's head off with
with a butter knife I'm thinking maybe
maybe a machete I don't know machete
butter knife whatever and he held it up
on YouTube in a bag and it took six
hours to take that down but there was no
nudity on it it was just a head in the
bag you know what I mean I mean this is
the things that ma maa does they put
heads in bags and they have pedophile
convoys that go down to Children's camps
close to the border to steal food from
orphans it's what they do it's the way
of Maga they cut their dad's head off
they show it on YouTube and they get in
pedophile convoys to go to the Border
what do you want from me these are just
things they
do but I'm surprised YouTube doesn't
flat maybe this is why I'm not monetized
on YouTube because I keep sh [__]
videos of this guy's neck [__] their
crowdsourcing now to ban my neck [__]
this country is pathetic it is pathetic
we should we should crowdsource to get
this guy some so we're we're not so
goddamn I mean the children are seeing
this stuff you know what I
mean children are seeing this stuff they
don't want to look at his [__] look at
this guy's
[__]
oh he's so [__] he's such an [__]
why why do these people like this guy
maybe that's why they like him because
of his neck
gin you know you know what's really
frustrating is yesterday I started
talking about Glenn kersner and there's
about two 300 people that left the
[__] broadcast but today I'm talking
about neck [__] and everyone's like oh
Tony's talking about necky come on let's
join
in
oh my God son of a [__] you want for me
all right here's probably what you want
for
me let's see I had another clip oh yeah
here's a good clip of um
uh of Grandpa neck [__] here's Grandpa
neck [__] now I don't know if you know
who this guy is um this guy is Dan
bino okay that's his name Dan he has me
blocked on Twitter because this guy is a
neck [__] too this guy has a neck [__]
and this guy is a neck [__] okay but
Dan
banino has me blocked on Twitter I don't
know why again it's probably because
he's a neck [__] but he's talking to
Grandpa neck [__]
here how many times can I say neck [__]
before people start getting offended
um so he's he's on the show but he's
just phoning it in right and the reason
why Grandpa's phoning it in cuz he
hadn't powdered his face and put the
[__] you know the spray tan on his
face and powdered his powdered his neck
vagge you know what I mean does he have
to does that thing does he have to like
every month does he have to make sure
it's not bleeding and [__] I don't I
don't know [__] what do you want from me
I don't know these things this is why I
don't try to pass laws to keep women
from doing health care and stuff because
I don't know about that stuff I'm asking
questions can a guy ask questions can a
guy ask question
ah but here's here's Grandpa neck [__]
on The Dan Bonino show see if you can
spot what Grandpa neck [__] calls Dan
his name is Dan okay listen thanks for
giving your first comments on the bill
on this show means a lot to us we
appreciate it sir thanks a lot you have
a deal thanks a lot bye Joe thanks
thanks for giving your first comments on
the bill on this show means a lot to us
we appreciate it sir thanks a lot you
have a deal thanks a lot you got it Joe
you got it Joe Joe
banino Joe banino thanks Joe now it's so
one or two things either either um he's
R he's his head is rotting from the neck
[__]
in oh God either his head is rotting
from the neck [__] in to his brain or
or Joe Biden lives rentree inside that
that neck [__] brain of his
100% um because he called Dan
Bonino um Joe and I don't know if Bon
Gino sounds like Brandon so maybe that's
how he got it confused Joe
Brandon I'm not sure I'm not sure how I
got it confused um but it is either way
either he doesn't know B Joe bongino's
name or he thinks he's Dan Brandon I
mean it could be Dan Bonino Dan Brandon
you know could be could be the same
thing I don't
[Laughter]
know oh boy maybe he needs to
um have a papshmear done check to make
sure that brain's still working I don't
know don't you think that's where they
would go to get to his brain is through
[Laughter]
his he's got a [__] on his neck
he's got a [__] [__] on his
neck oh my
God I don't know what to tell you what
do you want you know if you don't laugh
through this [__] you're not g to make
it through it you're really not um
here's um some white Christian
nationalist this guy is a preacher and
um he's gonna tell you all kinds of
things here it's weird stuff listen cuz
we're not here to Patty Cake we're here
to take
over hey that's what right-wing watch
and all these like to call me there's a
Dominion guy there's a guy that's trying
to take everything over what what we're
not here to Patty Cake we're here to
take over why do these people always
always always always do like children
stuff you notice that you notice
that right these [__] these white
these white Christian nationalists and I
know this guy's not white but he's a
white Christian nationalist you don't
have to be white to believe that white
people are superior okay that's a that's
not you you can be A different race and
believe that white people are superior
okay that is a
thing this guy this guy
here why does he say patty cake patty
cake is something that you play with
your baby and your toddler you know you
play PE peekaboo or patty cake patty
cake B that's what why do they always do
that
[__] huh why do you think they why do
you think they got that in their brains
like that it's [__] weird okay go
ahead I said yes I am for the King of
Kings and the Lord of
lords 2024 we're taking over in the name
of Jesus taking over in the name of
Jesus well you can tell your Jesus to go
to [__] hell okay we're not you're
not taking over any anybody anywhere
with the name of Jesus it's not going to
happen that's not what we're going to do
we as in the people who vote are not
going to put up with that [__] just
not going to happen speaking of um
speaking of racism and white people holy
[__] this clip here is really gonna show
you some wild ass [__] that these white
Christian nationalists believe and
they're always the victim right that's
why Trump is Calling America pathetic
he's like America's pathetic because
they want to put me in jail for the
crimes that I committed can you believe
that can you believe that I committed
crime and now they want to put me in
jail for trying to overthrow the G can
you believe that I tried to overthrow
the Govern now want to put me in jail
for
it I'm gonna be hell
accountable [__] goddamn White
Privilege like a
[__] but white people with this
um white Christian nationalist they're
like Reverse Racism you ever heard this
[__] before Reverse Racism where people
are racist against white people what in
the [__] are you talking about what the
[__] are you talk listen I grew up in
rule White
America some of the most racist
[__] I ever met I actually I
actually had someone tell me one time
I'm not racist I just don't like black
people okay white people have so much
[__] privilege so much so much
[__] privilege that they don't even
know what [__] racism is that's how
much privilege white people have trust
me I knows I is one okay I've walked
around as a white male my entire life
and I've had nothing but [__]
privilege no one has ever questioned
anything I've ever done ever never I've
done some wild and crazy [__] before no
one said a word because I'm a [__]
white dude okay that's how it works
that's how that's how it [__] works
and if you're not aware of how it works
you need to wake the [__] up you need to
shake loose and understand that there is
White
Privilege okay it's not but see the
problem is is these [__] white
Christian nationalists get white
privilege conf confused with white
supremacy right they think because
they're granted all these privileges
from a white society that they Superior
somehow of other people which is all
[__] complete nonsense right this is
dumb as [__] the dumbest [__] I've ever
heard and then when they say when they
say well I'm the victim I'm the one
who's oppressed because when when the
oppressor notices that other people get
rats then they feel oppressed they feel
oppressed and they feel like someone's
being racist against against them
because they're white this is dumb [__]
but listen the idea that there's some
widespread movement called the alt-right
that we have to deal with I think is a
fallacy and I also think and this is
really important primarily today the
racism in America comes from the left
this a yeah it comes from the left we're
the racist I'm I'm a racist you goddamn
right I'm a racist what the [__] are you
talking about man point to me point to
me of the policies on on the left the
[__] people on the left we're talking
about diversity Equity inclusion we're
talking about Liberty freedom and rights
no matter your race your Creed your
religion your
sexuality we don't even care how you
dress okay all right we don't give a
[__] we just don't want you telling us
what the [__] to do you [__] chud
what are you talking about racist on the
left point it out to me the problem of
the left I would absolutely agree you
know this
racism on the right is a total Fringe
thing oh the racist on the racism on the
right is a total Fringe thing so look H
the white Christian nationalists are
admitting there's a racist element to
the right because there is it's hard for
them to ignore they're like no no no
listen the racist people on the right
that we love the most um that's in The
Fringe and we really like that Fringe
but it is The Fringe let's hear where
the racis racism comes from though
racism on the left has become mainstream
in the sense of racism against white
people racism against white people shut
the [__] listen I am a white person okay
you do not get pastier than this [__]
white cracker right here all right not
only am I white I'm a man and I look
like a white cracker from rule Missouri
you know what I mean I look like I'm
from the goddamn Lake of the Ozarks and
I just walked off the set of Ozark okay
I sound like it too I get it I get it
most people listen when people first
meet me and they don't know who the [__]
I am and they don't know what I believe
a lot of people are like oh this guy's a
[__] racist there's no way that guy
looks like that and sounds like that and
ain't no [__] racist right yeah I'm
from Kami Falls
Missouri of course I'm from Kami Falls
Missouri
listen they they I and I can sense it I
can sense it from people when I meet new
people and they they sense that I'm some
kind of [__]
racist because I looks like one I sounds
like
one at one point in my life I was one
because I didn't know no [__] better
I didn't know no better and that's
what's happening here with this Reverse
Racism [__] is they're trying to
brainwash people who don't know no
[__] better reverse discrimination
reverse discrimination reverse
discrimination on the right is a total
Fringe thing racism on the left has
become mainstream in the sense of racism
against white people reverse
discrimination reverse
[Applause]
discrimination so diversity equity and
inclusion to make sure that policies and
companies and universities and
institutions aren't out there aren't
operating against racist principles to
make sure to keep I don't know nonwhite
people out of their institutions that's
not racist that's racist that's racist
as [__] against white people okay listen
your Dei your Equity your equality your
inclusion and your diversity it really
discriminates against my ability to rule
over you and for you to be to not be
second class citizens
that really is discriminating against my
white Su Supremacy okay it's really a
discriminatory uh shot across the bow
when you're talking about taking away my
white supremacy even though it's a thin
Bale lie that I'm a su that I'm more
Supreme get the [__] out of here with
this [__] and you know you're not
gonna hear anyone else talk about this
[__] the way I talk about it by the way
there's no [__] white person out
there that looks like me and talks like
me and does what I dud that that has the
balls to say this type of [__] in this
type of way and talk about this and the
reason why is because I fundamentally
understand one thing about this
conversation is most non-white people
most non-white people are not scared to
talk about race they're not they're not
scared to talk about it and neither
should you be you should not be scared
to defend against [__] [__] boxes
like this saying this type of [__] [__]
this [__] [__] her and her godamn
religion um racism on the right is a
total Fringe thing racism on the left
has become mainstream in the sense of
racism against white people
rever I'm so oppressed you [__] [__]
what a [__] [__] and really honestly
if we get tougher on these people like I
am if we get tougher on these [__]
people it won't take long it will not
take long for the Nazis like these two
promoting Ro reverse discrimination and
Reverse Racism get the [__] out of here
with that [__] if you're so goddamn
Superior then you don't have to yell and
scream how you're oppressed okay that's
how it [__] works it's the same idea
as an alpha male have you ever met one
of these [__] who has a t-shirt
that says I'm an alpha male H listen
listen [__] an alpha does not
have have to announce that they're an
alpha that's what makes them that okay
that's what makes them an alpha and
they're so rare real Alphas are so
[__] rare okay real ones like the
real one like if you've ever met an
alpha male you will [__] know it most
of them most of them end up in very
dangerous [__] prisons because alpha
males are not scared of [__] anything
and they're not scared of anyone and
they do not think that they no one can
tell them because they truly are alpha
they don't have to wear a t-shirt saying
I'm an alpha male that they bought at
the Gap okay it's not a thing the same
way as someone who is a superior race
doesn't have to point it out why why if
white people are so Superior do they
have to continue to always point that
[__]
out you don't see black people run
around like we're the superior race
we're the better ones we're better than
you we're so much better than you we're
better than you we're better than you
we're better than you we're better than
you you don't see that you don't see
that a
lot because they don't do that because
again Alphas don't have to wear a stupid
t-shirt from The Gap saying I'm an alpha
they don't I got one more thing um
because we do have let's see I think we
have
a no I thought we had another thought we
had another image here ah we're at a
time two full hours Boom the Tony
Michaels podcast that's right it's been
a great day a great show and I'm so
happy that all of you have joined the
Discord server make sure if you want to
get in on the absolute ground floor of
the [__] if you want to be part of
this Super Bowl news I'm telling you I
bet we can make the Super Bowl broadcast
we can [__] do it it's Tuesday
February 6 we got a few days left we got
to get in this Discord server we got to
start pumping out ideas and we got to
act on these ideas that's right we got
to get this out into the open that we're
going to change the name from the Kansas
City Chiefs
to the Kansas City swifties how about
those Kansas City
swifties yeah baby we're going to do it
we're going to change the name from the
Kansas City's Chiefs the Kansas City
swifties we're gonna make it happen
we're g to get this in the news the news
is going to talk about this I promise
you I promise you this is the way this
is the type of [__] that we need and
I'm telling you we're going to learn so
much from this this is an exercise folks
in how to commit [__] with the weapon
of mockery so that we the pro-democracy
Coalition can pile as many votes at the
ballot on top of these fascist [__] as
we possibly can in November it's
operation go commando time and operation
go commando says go to the Tony
michaels.com pan on down the memberships
join the Discord server today it is free
get
verified just go to the hashtag get
verified Channel and click the green
check mark just click the green green
check mark you'll get verified you'll
get access to all the [__] and all
the mockery and make sure to go join the
book club there too yeah we have book
club we have book club we don't just do
[__] I mean the book club is part of
[__] too it's all part of [__]
it's the [__] university over there
at the Tony Michaels podcast Discord
server so get in the Discord server now
and commit [__] but come back
tomorrow same time same place Sur up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podast in your
face commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
grab him by the neck [__] Murphy's me
Barn head ass
speaking
actually you know what I don't want to
get off this smous thing yet uh
more more smelter Skelter
here causing smelter SK look at that
[__] God damn look at that front butt W
baby did Elvis have a front butt like
that or is that a full diaper is that a
front butt or a full diaper I don't know
I'm not really sure o God damn holy holy
moly B Ho Holy front butt
Batman smelter
Skelter
whoosh